oh
[Musique]
e
où
almaty est ce le fait nuit du drame ou à
des risques et à chaque citoyen
[Musique]
à l'endroit mythique oui j'oubliais que
nous avons au niveau du crâne mario où
il ya déjà une belle route
[Musique]
c'est un bâtiment qui est abandonnée de
plus de plus de 45 ans et qu'il était
occupé que au rez de chaussée
donc il a beaucoup souffert de cet
abandon il y avait beaucoup de traces de
négligence de deux manque d'entretien de
déficiences des matériaux et même des
des cavités assez suspecte dans le
bâtiment qui qui signifie pour nous donc
un risque imminent donc de krul mans
mais
[Musique]
on n'est pas là
oh
où
e
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]